what was the idea behind putting this
together well this wasn't our first idea
we've course had like a big video idea
that me and Marcus had decided on it was
kind of a unique it was very weird a lot
of had a lot of special effects and was
super cool this happened like three
months ago got an idea for it and we had
a director that he loved what happened
was of course the quarantine so we had
to switch our idea is the song still
gotta come out where I can push back our
release dates loop of asylum is very
important we loved the record we had
finished a long time ago so we decided
that let the director have another idx
we said how can we just at home and be
creative and he came with a really good
concept between our friends us and then
a casting about two people all over the
world over 29 countries and artists and
people do amazing things to be in the
video so we shot it over the last month
and dad we're gonna show it here today
this video kind of feels like a global
group hug almost like a therapy session
well I think major lazer like that's
always been our our market we're gonna
worldwide we travel all over the world
just like Marcus and I'm lovin it sounds
a bit all over Africa but you know South
America Russia through Europe and I are
branded really special and in global
since the beginning so we wanted to
reach out then really we knew out there
that all the cast of directors in
different places I think is over - over
200 people in the video possibly people
who sang on the record with us people
that dance with us so yeah it does feel
kind of like a world of a message to the
world
yeah Marcus how did you get involved
with this just through words I mean I
showed up where's his house in LA and we
spent some time talking about music and
listen to music and making music
together and you know our bands always
been very collaborative and and the band
really supported me and collaborating
with Major Lazer on this from the
beginning really and and then of course
even during the making of it felt
collaborative you know mo helped write
the song as well she's a brilliant job
and then there are various people about
Daniel high and came along and saying
some back
vocals and the whole thing has felt like
a real collaboration right from the
start have you done a lot of
collaborations before yeah I mean our
band was born out of a collaborative you
know period in time when we were all
playing together in London playing in
each other's bands Azure where
ancestress and yeah we've collaborated a
lot with other artists but I've never
done anything as a featured artist
myself so this song almost sounds like
it was written for this moment in time
but but it wasn't actually yeah that's a
coincidence we'd written it we wrote it
last year and but and the release date
was set a while ago and just so happened
that it was the kind of song that I
think people respond to in fact it was
one year ago because I know it was on
Earth Day we wrote it mmm that's right
there cuz we went out to like a party in
my house and there was a constant are
friend played for free in a park it was
a Earth Day celebration that's literally
one year ago
yes we're gonna coming out yeah sort of
day again which one of the groups is in
the video where that from the
dreamcatchers Academy yeah can you tell
me about them they're from Nigeria I
mean we wanted to reach out to anybody
that we could all over the world that
was doing something special um unique
and these are kids that we knew from
from Nigeria that that dance they sing
it's a it's a free school for kids who
want to like empower themselves and
learn about music for you know mostly
street kids kids I don't have access to
better schools and that's one example
we've been in my gia many times and we'd
loved it there I mean even the music
itself the beat lends itself to like
Nigerian house music that's happening
right now so it's kind of a global sound
it's a mix with you know Marcus has his
folky Americana Boys Major Lazer's
always kind of got this worldwide dance
music and we went to Africa for some of
the percussion and I think that kind of
makes the sound of the record as worldly
as what we want the video you know in
the experience yeah I know I'm sure you
guys weren't there for when they shot
all these these different performances
what did you think when you saw all the
performances we know when I had the idea
for the video when we had the concept
Kent came to us I was a bit hesitant
because I didn't want to go around
asking our fan
cent submit content you know I didn't
want to feel like we were like desperate
for people to give us videos and what we
did is we said let's find the best
people in the world that can do this
from home and we just and we literally
casted it instead of being like an open
source so I was kind of has to when I
got back I was like wow this cuz how can
you make a video like this you know how
can you make a video during quarantine I
feel like every the same ideas yeah
coming from home but there's something
special about this video because it
feels real it feels like the real
experience is for each person and I
think the messages of the music and the
people felt it and the choreography was
amazing I was done by Ryan Heffington
there's an amazing choreography works
let's see a nice sometimes and everybody
followed it he just I got I got goose
bumps the first day that I saw and I
wasn't even in yet I had to be in it and
that's all Marcus he was so he was so
effortless on his bed yeah I just had to
beat it I had to beat it what Marcus
when did you actually shoot you're part
of this yeah a couple weeks ago and lock
down my wife shot the whole thing she
was but she was camera operator on the
first date
no I well the problem is I didn't we
were you know we came across all the
same issues that everyone trying to do
zoom calls from home right now has
barking dogs and crying children so we
had a feed cracks at it but it was it
was good fun Ashley and yeah I was the
same as where his first first cut I saw
I just thought this is perfect for this
moment time it looked like you were
sitting on your kitchen table I was at
one point yeah yeah yeah my kids came in
were like what are you doing against the
rules you know that's against the rules
yeah it was I mean it was just trying to
find places you know where it felt all
right to play guitar it's a pretty weird
one but yeah yeah I mean there's a whole
spirit to the whole video which was just
try it and see what happens and I think
that was the spirit that really got
through to everyone that was cast to
just try it like if you make a fool of
yourself that's fine how are you both
doing in quarantine in effect I'm in LA
it's it's doesn't feel that different my
life like I'm on the road I'm usually on
tour all
or maybe 300 days of the year so it
feels like an extended break from tour
but um at least la seems pretty
sufficient is people are doing great
deal bit the the rules here we haven't
had a big outbreak like New York City or
in Europe so we've been safe here it's a
bit boring that's about it but I'm lucky
that I'm lucky to be happy and healthy
you know actually I really needed a
break so I'm on that kind of mad I can't
I can't work but I I'm trying to look at
the positive I'm taking advantage of
every moment I have I'm home and I'm
constant things I wouldn't do otherwise
like I'm trying to learn how to take
it's hard better I'm trying to learn
playing whatever I can paint whatever I
can do this things I would never I never
do you know you know take it you got a
look at look for the opportunities you
did you actually did a couple of weeks
in in quarantine when you came off tour
was that right
I think the first the first weekend that
felt serious wasn't the ABA was canceled
than Tom Hanks you know came down with
it and the next day that there was a
travel ban from Europe and I thought I
just don't or then all I've been in
Mexico Brazil I'd done carnival and my
children live near nearby me in a house
and they they live with the grandmother
and I uh I went to visit them but from
outside so I told him like look I don't
know what's going on this could be a a
Centon egg situation so I got tested by
my doctor and it took like seven days
eight days had to stay on from them just
visiting them from outside the window
and I came back negative so I've been
going and visiting them you know every
day since then but I did take it take it
very safely in the beginning how are you
doing in in isolation Marcus yeah we're
okay it feels like a family time you
know we spend much more time with your
family than you might otherwise
certainly like when we're on tour and I
get to see my family this much and my
parents are with us you're in
self-isolation too so it's complicated
you know juggling plates and all
spending a lot more time together than
we'd expected but I think we're gonna
look back and think of it as a
neighborly time you know time we got
spend more time with our families and
look at look look out for our neighbors
literal neighbors in a way that we
hadn't before so I think there's some
you know there's solace in the community
I didn't know I had as many name
like 400 marques have you found any new
hobbies while you're at all I've been
working man I'm in the studio here at
the time I thought it was a really smart
idea to build a studio at home and I
sort of regret it I've been working away
and scoring a TV show and you know been
been doing various calls and people and
trying to do live performances on
Instagram and stuff just it's been quite
full-on actually I'm actually busier
than I I know that feeling actually I
didn't have a studio at home but now it
seems I do Yeah right when you were
working you work on this show for Jason
Sudeikis right for appletv and the song
that you put out was was that originally
intended for that show yeah that was the
cover of you'll never walk alone the
Rodgers and Hammerstein song which is
really well known here in the UK is a
song associated with Liverpool Football
Club but this is a song that I had at my
sleeve I'd recorded it in January for
this TV show Jason because it's about
soccer
Jason had asked me to record a version
of it which I did with my friend Reuben
James and then we had it up our sleeves
and just felt like might as well get it
out sooner rather than later so we put
it out actually for Warchild UK her
children complet in the States and and
the grunt profession both of which I'm
involved with and put it out yeah so the
first weekend of proper lockdown here
just to keep people company really and
direct them towards these two
organizations that have a pretty
difficult job anyway and even more
surgery these times Wes have you have
you you've done some terrible stuff too
you did some of this past weekend right
yeah I'm still trying to pretend that I
have a job so I'm DJing every Thursday
Friday Saturday and Sunday on runs on
Twitch and Instagram and in the Saturday
we gave away door - gifts to everybody
who everybody who viewed our stream
which is almost like 20,000 people we we
matched with a meal from door - charades
people who needed food you know
basically so there is cool ways to do
that because the streaming services have
a little revenue it's kind of Calista
find some charity charity causes and
actually collects some money right now
people which is great we've been doing
that every weekend
just been busy and giving people
entertainment because I think do you
know working dance Musa colada this is
the one time where you there's nowhere
for that to go and club music cuz people
can go to bars and they can go to they
can't dance they can't go to festivals
so just to keep that part alive for
young people to have some fun you know
it's not always about sitting and been
feeling sad for stuff you can kind of
have a good time to party your house and
we try to do that every every weekend
what do you want folks to take away from
from this video that you're putting out
um I think the message is in the song
that Marcus wrote you know it originally
felt like an ode to caring for someone
you love in mental health and in a
special way but you know it sounds
cheesy but when you concentrate on the
lyrics it felt it got better every time
he changed it about 10 different times
like little parts the bursts where the
message was really clear it's about you
know showing someone some some support
when you can and in a loving way I think
this was one time in the world where we
can do that with our family our friends
and like he said our neighbours that we
don't have received normally because you
kind of gotta take care of everybody
around you now it's not just that your
family and you you really need to
concentrate on taking care your
neighbors and people close to you even
if it's people in your city people in
your country people all over the world
wearing it together that's what's great
about this video Marcus I feel like as a
celebration a human spirit you know and
the things that people can do and the
beauty of people even in their homes you
know I think it's you strip everything
away strip away all the bells and the
whistles and the fancy stuff and fancy
cameras or special effects and it's
completely opposite to the idea for the
video we had before which I hope one day
we make anyway but it included horses
and West carrying horses and it was
crazy and awesome but with this is just
people at home like people playing
instruments people dancing people with
their neighbors and spreading this
message that we love in this song that
we've done together and yeah it's just I
think it's a celebration of people at
home I'm sorry to say something well the
other video actually had me carrying
horses and Marcus bumper was like doing
karate with his guitar on fire at one
point so maybe we could find a way to do
that once all over because I really want
to see one Bastien I'd like to see that
too
looking forward for that one you know
things get back to normal
thank you both for doing this thanks
again thank you really enough so look
with everything hang in there thank you
that's not bye guys